[Music]  tell me story tell me every detail a  woke up somewhere from the nightmare  what was it about then Thanks then mean  lots to care of their business  hold a folder back up you've left  something out are you writing a book  they all lived happily ever after no  they didn't know that because for the  first time there's something you don't  know  something nobody told you  [Music]  you wanted to prophesy this is your  prophecy no man from hunting faint I'm  worried I don't kind of man you are what  are they my lord Gary I now your story  behold the man who pulled sword from  stone I'm not getting drawn into this  mess there's an army of you it's only  one of me I'll talk I'm happy to talk  but there is no way the I am fighting  fares here  so what happens now you know happens now  you quickly becoming a legend  [Music]  [Music]  you